it looks like Covington high school
student Nick Sandman has scored a legal
win after being smeared by the media CNN
has settled a 250 million dollar
defamation suit Sandman filed it's over
a confrontation with the Native American
man that made the teenager look like the
aggressor here a look back at just some
of the media coverage
some students harassing an older Native
American man a Vietnam vet in the midst
of a special ceremony it does look like
that young man to me is taunting the
Native American Vietnam vet this
face-to-face confrontation igniting
charges of racism the kid mix Sandman he
doesn't seem to be afraid but he did
make a choice and that was to make it
into a standoff that was not a good
choice Greg Elmo does not look good
there as good-looking as he is though he
keeps going to the gym I want to know
how much money this was settled for and
will never know it drives me crazy but
this is really good news for everybody
on the planet because it's a turning
point before there really wasn't any
consequences to social media mobber e in
the canceled culture where somebody
could dig up something from Brian Brian
or Juan's past and just destroy you
just destroy you not you Shannon because
yours but now if you know that somebody
can sue you that changes your behavior
and if you don't have deep pockets I
mean it's your company's got to be
worried so I think this is could put an
end to the swarm that thing that happens
when somebody finds out you said some
how stupid when you were 16 so I'm I I
hope they hope they got something good I
hope think tinkin education a moment for
reporters everywhere that you should be
interested in the facts not the
narrative first I hope you're always
interested in the facts first but you
know I just don't know what this means I
think that a lot of people who are who
don't like CNN are quick to rush and say
oh this is mean CNN you know admitted
that they did I think you know you
I know lawyers the lawyers are like well
if we have to go through discovery then
that means emails and discussions were
are gonna be revealed we may not want
that out I don't know if the kid got a
dollar but I'd certainly can tell you as
I sit here I don't think he got 250
million ten percent ten percent yeah
they're still suing NBC in the
Washington Post and 13 more defendants
are going to be named ABC CBS The
Guardian Huffington Post NPR and slate
and the hill are all coming up with
Laguna get hit with lawsuits
well one like you said when you go into
discovery I mean I used to have clients
who you would talk to them and say
listen this is how much it's gonna cost
you to go to trial this is what they
want in settlement what do you want to
do and some people would say yeah we
don't want all that stuff out there
we'll pay I had other clients who would
say we will not pay a dime because what
we're worried about is if we pay this
person the next one's gonna want it the
next one in the next one
so CNN had to make a lot of calculations
here that you know what just beyond the
legal issues
yeah but Brian aren't third questions
about you know how the media handled
this I mean they really they went after
a teenager they did it because he was
wearing a mag a hat they said all these
horrible things about him is really he
was his reputation was destroyed and put
on the put on the internet for a white
kid take it in and then they didn't back
up and give the same amount of coverage
to the entire context of the story as
they did to the immediate narrative that
they all put up absolutely and that's
why they are the aggressive I know what
you're saying Shannon a lot of people
big companies don't want to go through
it they write to check but in this case
this kid asks for an apology on if they
just say listen I blew it this thing
would've been over so if you're that
worried about your reputation which
looks bad now because you've admitted
your guilt and wrote a check we don't
know how big as much as Greg needs to
know and I'm very curious to know this
kid should get a money a lot of money
he's gonna apply to colleges now how
many college is gonna go I don't need
this
I don't need this I could hire that kid
I don't I don't need I don't need he
should not go to college you should take
the money and start a business man it's
mixed money call me Nick I'll take care
of everything your experience you have
known
you know what he told me the other day
[Music]